i've seen some interesting responses
around
the room let's see if we can gather them
together
polar form on its own ends up being not
dissimilar to rectangular in that you
are about to substitute and then you're
like oh oh is that it right what happens
you've got two things here
both being raised to the power of n so
therefore you end up with an
r to the power of n and then all the
rest of this thing
also to the power of n d do you agree
and then we're kind of in exactly the
same boat here
as we were here you're like oh a
binomial
don't want to expand that we'll see what
happens there okay so i'm just going to
pause at that moment
but when we come to exponential form and
we shouldn't be that surprised
because it's a form named after
what we're doing right now this is
exponentiation that we're exploring
right now yeah
you end up with something a little more
useful what happens
well um you get the same out of the end
hanging out the front
yes but then because this is in index
form
what happens when you raise something
like this to the power of n what do you
do with that index
yeah you multiply those together right
so i guess i could write it as e to the
power of i
and theta are you okay with that now
what i like about this
is go back to friday's lesson we proved
a big bad formula
that tells me what this thing means
right do you remember i was named after
a famous mathematician
his name was lenoilla right swiss
mathematician
and he proves something to do with e to
the i
x right what was that equal to
it should look really familiar to stuff
we've written on the board right say it
again louder
very nice cos x plus i sine x by the way
um we did that informal proof on friday
go and have a look at the canvas page
you'll see the big
long formal proof that's there i hope
you get something out of that now have a
look at this right is not this
e to the power of ix for a particular
value
of x what value of x is in here
what's the x that's it's n theta isn't
it
that there is the x so therefore i can
substitute it for
this all the x's i'll substitute for an
n theta does that make sense
so let's have a go at this maybe this is
not where your line has gone but i'd
love you to follow with me
i'm now going to have this with n thetas
instead of x's
that okay so i'm going to get cos of n
theta
plus i sine of n theta
that double end looks a bit weird maybe
put some brackets around it if you feel
more comfortable okay does that look
better to you okay now here's what we
can do now this is where we're sort of
looking at this same object but from
two angles right all of these are z to
the end they're all the same object
right but if i call this guy say
equation one
call this one equation two this is just
like simultaneous equations right i can
equate these two
and get an important result out of it
let's write that down if i'm equating
one and two because they're both equal
to z of
n yes you're following why i'm doing
this uh you can see you've got r to the
n
and all of the stuff in here
also to the power of n and then you've
got out of the normal time
and then this which we got out of uh
euler's formula
now it looks to me like there's a big
old common factor on both sides what can
i divide through by
left and right say it again that
r to the power of n right it's common on
both sides so
i could divide both sides by that
and that leaves me with a really
important result which is going to be
our subheading i told you i'd come back
to it
if you just take the trigonometric terms
and their powers
this formula that we just end up with
right named after another
mathematician not euler this is a french
mathematician
named abraham de moivre now
i have found about 15 pronunciations
for this guy's name on the internet but
i asked a french teacher because we
happen to have french teachers here
how do i pronounce this name and she
told me the that's the easy part
moi like as in me and then
well the way it's spelt okay not
de moivre like he's not spanish okay um
demarva's theorem
this thing down here is phenomenally
useful
we're going to use it we get handed this
complex number right let's
jot it down together we have z equals 1
plus
i tend to like to write the i on the n
so 1 plus root 3
i but i r 3 is the same deal okay now
what they want us to do you can see the
real question in part b
is raise this thing this thing here to
the 11th
power boy do i not want to do that in
rectangular form
that's a bad idea there's going to be 12
terms hopefully that will simplify out
but
that's that's nobody's idea of a good
time so instead you can see part a
there's sort of
helpfully nudging us to say maybe try a
different form here right
so part a let's express this in mod arg
form
in polar form what are the two things we
need for mod
arg form a modulus and an argument so
let's go ahead and
work out the modulus here uh the modulus
of z
i can get from pythagoras it's gonna be
the square root of this squared plus c
squared
right one plus three so you're gonna get
yes this is why i come to the extension
2 class we can do
arithmetic okay so i've got a modulus
now okay now the next thing is i'm
looking for an
argument now mr lee's already talked
before about
principal arguments so i just want to
remind you we have these
ever so slightly different pieces of
notation for this when you see that
augzit
right it's like argument angle to get to
a point sometimes when we definitely
definitely want you to provide
the principal argument will capitalize
the a but it's a teeny tiny thing that
you often miss
okay um thankfully this guy's in the
first quadrant anyway so it's hard to
miss the principal argument
how are we going to get it we can say
cos
theta and sine theta
of the basis of all the numbers in here
how will you combine the numbers you can
see on the board to get cos theta
which part is it have a think
you've got a a horizontal and a vertical
component which one's cosine
it's the it's the first one right it's
one over
two do you agree over the modulus and
then this
leaves root three over two and we know
the angle that does this right what's
the argument that i'm after it's going
to be pi on
3 fantastic part 3.
got my modulus got my argument so i can
say therefore z
equals 2 cos pi
on 3 plus i sine pi
on 3. happy times so that's our setup as
we go into part b
now they're saying well okay can you
raise this thing to the power
of 11 and then return me back into
rectangular form that's where sort of
we're heading right we started there so
we're going to end there
right so when i go to part b i
don't want to use this original form i'm
going to use this form right
but according to de moivre's theorem
right i can sort of do a lot of this
leg work really easily right for
starters that module's out the front
if you raise that to the power of 11
what you're going to get
2 to the power of 11 right if you're a
nerd like me then you know 2 to the
power of ten
is a thousand twenty four so the next
one is two thousand forty eight
um a few years ago there was a game that
was all anyway it doesn't matter
i'm showing my age um that's my modulus
it gets huge because you're doing this
over and over again so you scale many
many times and you're enormous okay
according to de moivre's theorem i'm
raising to the power of 11.
so what happens to my angles
they get multiplied by 11. okay so
instead of pi on 3
i'm gonna have 11 pi on 3
plus i sine 11 pi
now just like with pythagoras just like
with euler any time you invoke something
you should say where it comes from so i
will stay in here right
by de moivre's theorem
bless you wow okay so
yeah is it necessary to when we are
doing a
question about like people obviously do
we always need to say
bye so um do we need to quote this
uh let me answer that question by asking
you another one when you were in year 7
and 8 and you first
learned about hypotenuses in right angle
triangles
did you always have to talk about that
ancient greek mathematician every time
you do calculation
answer no really
in your seven and eight no you should
have
when you were doing pythagoras theorem
this is explaining a few things to me
now anyhow
i'm writing this here because you should
be writing it
okay especially because it's new yeah we
don't write it we
won't get much if you don't write it
what you are
saying to me is i'm not interested in
clearly communicating the reasoning in
my argument
and that may result in you losing marks
so i'm writing it because i think you
should too
now you could if you want to reach your
calculator and do
cos of eleven pound three but before you
do that like go and do that
when you've tried this with your own
brain and confirm you got the right
answer
let's not go there yet i've got 2048 out
the front
i want you to think with me right the
more you do this with your brain the
better
your brain will get doing it eleven
pounds three is this enormous angle
right eleven pi three means you go round
and round and round and round and round
but cos and sign right cos and sign
because they go round and round and
round they're
periodic functions do you remember that
they are periodic every what's their
period how often do they repeat two pi
radians right
so the closest multiple to this that i
can think of would be
12 pi on three that would be pretty
close right
so 12 pi on 3 forwards or backwards of
this angle would be the same angle do
you agree
so instead i'm going to i'm going to
subtract
12 pi on 3. that would give me negative
pi and 3. are you okay with that
you see the equivalent right uh i've got
the same thing
over here
so i'm taking advantage of the
periodicity
of the trigonometric functions and then
because i'm so exceptionally lazy i can
go one step even better than that right
2048 still hanging out the front cos is
not just a periodic function
it's also a symmetrical function it's
even
right so cos of negative anything is
just because of
the same positive angle right so that's
cos of pi on three
which i already know right we've got
this from the start
um here sine doesn't have it has
symmetry but not the same kind of
symmetry it's not
an even function it's odd so therefore
this negative part
3 it can become a negative out the front
and i'm doing this again because i know
what sine pine 3 is
so that makes sense now did you have to
do this leg work in the question
no but the more you do this the better
your brain gets at noticing these
and then when you do reach for your
calculator you'll know why you are
correct
okay so i think we've got a half out
here we've got
what have i got root 3 on 2 i
i'm not even going to write the next
line because i reckon you can handle it
those halves can factorize out
so you should leave should leave you
with 1024
uh minus 1024 root 3
hi maybe i will write that because that
sounded longer than i'd like to remember
so
1024 minus 1024
root three i there's my solution okay
so you can see how powerful something
like demarvorous theorem is it just sort
of makes mincemeat of questions like
this